مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم لا احتمال
لتصعيد عسكري والحصار كان غير مرحب به
الكلام على لسان وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
بوريس جونسون خلال زيارته للكويت قبيل
وصوله الدوحه اللافت ان الوزير استخدم في
حديثه عن الازمه تعبير الحصار ولعله
التعبير الادق لوصف الاجراءات البريه
والبحريه والجويه التي اتخذتها دول خليجيه
ضد قطر في كل الاحوال تصريح رئيس
الدبلوماسيه البريطاني جاء قبل يومين من
وصول نظيره الامريكي ريكس تيلرسون الى
منطقه الخليج سعيا لمناقشه ازمه يبدو ان
بوصله حلها تتخذ وجهه جديده تقرير مريم
اويش وزير الخارجيه البريطاني بورس جونسون
في جوله للخليج الساخن جدا سياسيا ومناخ
قطر هي المحطه الثالثه لرئيس الدبلوماسيه
البريطانيه في الدوحه اجرى محادثات مع
امير قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني ووزير
الخارجيه محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني وفي
الكويت كان جونسن قد التقى بالنائب الاول
لرئيس مجلس الوزراء ووزير الخارجيه
الكويتي الشيخ صباح خالد الحمد الصباح كان
صريحا امن وحده البيت الخليجي من امن
بريطانيا استنادا لوكاله الانباء الكويتيه
اعرب جونسون عن قلق بلاده من استمرار
الازمه الراهنه كما نشد جميع الاطراف
العمل على احتواء الاحتقان والتعجيل
بايجاد حل عبر الحوار وفي تصريح لوكاله
اخرى بدد الوزير البريطاني المخاوف من
تفاقم
الازمه ليس هناك احتمال لتصعيد العسكري
وما يريده الناس باعتقادي هو عكس التصعيد
نعتقد ان الحصار لم يكن موضع ترحيب ونامل
ان يكون هناك خفض لتصعيد ولكن بالطبع نحن
نعمل وندعم اصدقائنا الكويتيين على
تفاهمات لكيفيه المضي قدما في محاربه
تمويل الارهاب لا من قبل قطر فقط ولكن
ايضا من طرف جميع اصدقائنا في
المنطقه للتوضيح الوزير البريطاني استخدم
مصطلح الحصار الذي لا يق لرباع الحمله ضد
قطر وقبل ان يرفع النقاب عن الخطوات التي
تتوعد تلك الدول الدوح بها بعد رفضها
المطالب او الادعاءات الث3 ع تستمر
الاصوات الغربيه الداعيه الى حوار بناء
ينهي الخلاف اخيرا قررت واشنطن الاقتراب
جغرافيا من من الازمه التي تناقضت فيها
بدايه المواقف بين البيت الابيض ووزارتي
الخارجيه والدفاع سيحل وزير الخارجيه ريكس
تيلرسون يوم الاثنين ضيفا على الكويت التي
تتوسط بين قطر والثلاثي الخليجي زائد مصر
لا يعرف هل سيكتفي بالاستماع ام ينوي
التاثير في طرف او جميع الاطراف وغير
الجمله الشهيره لاغلب المسؤولين الغربيين
بشان ضروره وقف تمويل الارهاب ماذا بعد
وما هو الجديد بشان
الازمه ردت الدوحه يوم الجمعه على بياني
دول الحصار بان ما ورد فيهما تهم باطله
تمثل تشهيرا يتنافى مع الاسس المستقره
للعلاقات بين الدول في يوم من ايام
القطيعه بالحصار برا وبحرا وجوا اصوات
تنادي للتهدئه وراب الصدع واخرى تتوعد
بمزيد من الاجراءات ضد قطر في الوقت
المناسب هل من المناسب جهاض كل مساعي
التسويه مقابل تاجيج نار فتنه لن يسلم احد
من لهبها من مصلحه من جعل عباره خليجنا
واحد من الماضي
القريب ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدبلوماسي
الامريكي السابق باتريك روس وكذلك من
الكويت الدكتور ماجد الانصاري استاذ علم
الاجتماع السياسي في جامعه قطر اهلا بكم
ابدا معك دكتور ماجد الانصاري وانت تحدثنا
اليوم من الكويت التي انطلق منها
زارها جونسون وانطلق منها الى الدوحه في
اطار زيارته وجولته الخليجيه بدايه يعني
كيف تستشعر مسار هذه الوساطه الكويتيه لا
سيما بعد زياره جونسون الى الكويت وما
اطلقه منها من
تصريحات نعم مساء الخير لك ولمش مشاهدين
جميعا من وطن النهار الكويت حقيقه يبدو
ان الوساطه الكويتيه ما زالت تتلقى ذات
الدعم المتواصل من مختلف القوى العالميه
يعني احنا وجدنا خلال الايام الماضيه
تاكيدا عاليا جدا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على اهميه هذه الوساطه على
الرغم م ما ورد في
بياني دول الحصار والذي كان بشكل غير
مباشر يوحي بانتهاء هذه الوساطه او كما
قال البيان الاخير بفشلها وهذا حقيقه كان
امرا محبطا بشكل كبير للشعوب الخليجيه
تحديدا ولجميع الاطراف في الازمه ان يقال
ان هذه الوساطه فشلت او او افشلت بهذا
الشكل والقاء اللائم طبعا على قطر كان
امرا غير منطقي في ضوء تعنت دول الحصار
ورفضها للقبول بمبدا الوساطه ومبدا
التفاوض الذي طالب به مختلف القوى ومنها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والان وزاره
الخارجيه البريطانيه طبعا عن ما وجدناه في
زياره وزير الخارجيه البريطاني هو امرين
رئيسيين الاول هناك استبعاد ل
التصعيد العسكري واضح واظن هذا ياتي ليكون
جوهره التاج في مجموعه كبيره من التصريحات
التي استبعدت التصعيد من هذا النوع خلال
الفتره الماضيه مما يدل على يبدو ان هناك
تاكيدات واضحه جدا وكما هو يعني الوضع على
الميدان يشير الى ذلك بان تصعيد اكثر من
الاطار السياسي والاقتصادي لم يعد
اصلا ممكنا لذلك كان هذا كان الخيار
العسكري مطروحا حتى يتحدث عنه الى اي حد
كان مطروحا هذا الخيار العسكري
ليتحدث عنه الوزير
البريطاني هو طبعا نفيه بهذا الشكل ونفي
ان يصل الى التصعيد ان يصل الى الجانب
العسكري هذا هو في بحد ذاته تاكيد على ان
كانت هناك مخوفات او او تخوفات من ان نصل
الى هذه المرحله وهذه التخوفات لا اظن ان
وزيره مثل وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
بالمعلومات الاستخباراتيه التي يقف او تقف
خلفه قبل ان يتكلم لا اظن انه سيلقي هذه
الكلمه جزاف لا شك ان التخوف هذا كان مبني
على وقائع كان مبني على اتصالات كان مبني
على معلومات استخباراتيه لذلك يبدو ان هذا
الامر في يوم ما كان مطروحا ولو كاحد
السيناريوهات
ما نطمئن اليه الان هو ان هذا السيناريو
اصبح
مستبعدا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني كذلك كان
مهما ما قاله حول تاكيده على وساطه الكويت
لينضم بذلك الى وزير الخارجيه الالماني
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي والبيت الابيض
الذين اكدوا جم جميعا على ان وساطه الكويت
باقيه وساطه سمو امير الكويت باقيه وهي
السبيل الى حل هذه الازمه سيد يرس يعني
كان لافتا ان بورس جونسون استخدم كلمه
الحصار في توصيف ما تواجهه قطر وقال ان
امن الخليج من امن بريطانيا برايك الى اي
مدى يتقاطع هذا الموقف البريطاني مع موقف
الولايات
المتحده من هذه الازمه
الخليجيه
الاعمران متقاربان لا اعتقد ان احدا في
الولايات المتحده يخالف ما قاله جونسون
استخدام كلمه حسار او مقاطعه هذه نقطه
مهمه جدا ينبغي التمييز بينهما في الخليج
نحن نفهم بان هذا اكثر من مجرد مقاطعه
واقل قليلا من حصار كامل بل هو محاوله
للاضرار باقتصاد قطر ولكن بدون ان يضر هذا
باناس اخرين على سبيل المثال حصار كامل
سوف يؤثر على عمل قطر المتعلق بالغاز
المسال وهذا يسبب ازمه عالميه ان تاثر هذا
القطاع النقاشات في بريطانيا والولايات
المتحده لا يميزان بين الامرين فهي ليست
قضيه مهمه كثيره بل هناك محاولات ل
فيفرض عمل من شانه ان يصلح بدون ان يضر
بالناس في قطر او حتى خارج قطر اذا كان
هناك ادراك بان ما يجري هو اكثر من مقاطعه
اذا كان هناك ادراك امريكي بذلك برايك
يعني لماذا تاخرت الخطوه الامريكيه نحن
نعلم بان ترسن يتوجه الى المنطقه بعد
يومين لماذا ترك الازمه تدخل شهرها الثاني
او اسبوعها الخامس حتى
ياتي ترسن الى المنطقه اذا كان هذا ادراك
امريكي بانه اكثر من
مقاطعه مره
اخرى كما قلت انفا
الازمه لم تاتي من فراغ الجميع لم يكن
جاهزا الولايات المتحده مازالت تعاني لان
السيد تسون ليس لديه موظفين
في وزاره الخارجيه وهو يدير الشؤون
الخارجيه كلها للولايات المتحده
لوحده وكان هناك امل حسب ما اعتقد كما في
الماضي بان الوساطه الكويتيه ستنجح واحد
الامور التي نتوقعها من خلال الخلافات
السائده بين الدول العربيه بان هناك
بيانات قويه ومن ثم ياتي دور الوساطه لكي
يتمكن الجميع من ان يحلوا هذه ازمه اذا
فهذه الازمه تاخذ بعدا لم يتوقعه اي منا
ولا احد توقع بانه سيكون هناك مطالب ترتقي
الى مستوى هدنه يجب ان ترفض ولم يتوقع احد
بان هذه الدول ستضع نفسها بعيدا في هذا
الموقف الصعب جدا وكما قلت نحن معتادون
على الدول العربيه تختلف فيما بينها ومن
ثم يتدخل شخص مثل الكويتيين للوساطه ن نعم
لكن يعني سيد ارس السيد ارس عفوا على
مقاطعتك استضفت ك قبل ذلك في بدايات هذه
الازمه
وربما
تشابه تشابهت اجاباتك بان تلسن لم يتوجه
الى المنطقه بسبب عدم وجود الموظفين وان
امريكا ليست جاهزه بعد لكن يعني ما الذي
دفع الغرب الان الى هذا التحرك العملي
وعلى هذا
المستوى اليوم نحن يعني دخلنا او دخلت هذه
الازمه شهرها
الثاني لا اريد ان اكون متشائما واعتقد
اننا اخيرا قمنا بتنظيم انفسنا لكي نرى ما
الذي يجب فعله اعتقد ان هذا الامر
هو مرتبط
باداره الاداره الامريكيه و علاقاتها في
هذه المنطقه ا سيد الانصاري يعني الوزير
البريطاني ايضا التقى اليوم امير دوله قطر
الشيخ تميم بن حمد و كذلك وزيره خارجيته
ما مدى تعويل قطر على الدور البريطاني على
دور بريطاني في حل هذه الازمه
برايك انا في تقديري اننا عندما نتكلم عن
جهود الوساطه التي تقوم بها مختلف الدول
كل اضافه الى هذه الجهود لا شك انه ايجابي
خاصه لما يك كون من دوله مثل المملكه
المتحده التي تجمعها بدول الحصار وبقطر
علاقات اساسيه جدا على المستوى الاقتصادي
هناك ارث تاريخي للعلاقات بين بريطانيا
والمنطقه وهناك تفهم او فهم عالي جدا لدى
الاداره البريطانيه ولدى مؤسسه الخارجيه
البريطانيه للوضع في منطقه الخليج
والمنطقه العربيه يتجاوز حقيقه حتى مثيله
في في واشنطن واشنطن كانت دائما ضيفا على
المنطقه بينما كانت المملكه المتحده فتره
من فرات ضيفا مقيما وبالتالي هي لديها
استيعاب ل ديناميكيه العلاقات السياسيه في
المنطقه وطبيعه المجريات السياسيه في
المنطقه بشكل ربما يتفوق على غيرها لذلك
سيكون من المهم ان نرى ا كيف ممكن ان يضيف
البريطانيون على جهود الوساطه التي يقوم
بها امير الكويت ولكن هنا ايضا نؤكد على
ان هذا الموقف ياتي متناسقا مع موقف
الولايات المتحده وموقف الاتحاد الاوروبي
على الرغم من وجود خلافات بين بريطانيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي وبين بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي وال الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الا ان الموقف من هذه الازمه يبدو انه
موقف واحد وموقف راسخ يدعو الى امرين
رئيسيين اولا احترام وساطه سمو امير
الكويت وان تكون هذه الوساطه هي السبيل
الى حل الازمه والامر الثاني هو ان يبدا
التفاوض طبعا لو لاحظنا اليوم على لسان
وزير الخارجيه في تصريحاته المختلفه سواء
كان في الكويت او في الدوحه او غير ذلك
نجد ان هناك نبره تفاؤل عاليه جدا ربما لم
تكن موجوده في تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الالماني نتمنى طبعا ان تستمر هذه النبره
بعد ان يكمل وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
جولته في المنطقه لانه حتى الان زار
الكويت وقطر التان تقفان موقفا ايجابيا من
هذه الازمه الان سنرى كيف ستكون تصريحاته
بعد زيارته لبقيه عواصم المطقه بهذه
الزياره وزير الخارجيه دعى الى رفع الحصار
عن قطر دعى الى تفاهم لمكافحه تمويل
الارهاب من جميع الاصدقاء في المنطقه وليس
فقط من قطر هل ترى هنا هنا يعني موقفا
بريطانيا فقط ام ربما اورو
غربيا وربما امريكيا
دكتور هو الموقف سواء كان في بريطانيا او
في الاتحاد الاوروبي عبر المانيا او فرنسا
او في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يكاد
يكون متجانسا بالكامل فيما يتعلق بالازمه
واظن حقيقه ان ما نسمعه من تصريحات يجب ان
يوضع في سياقه الطبيعي بمعنى ان اننا
عندما ان نسمع عندما نسمع تصريحات اوروبيه
او امريكيه في الرياض او نسمع تصريحات
بهذا المعنى في ابو ظبي ونسمع تصريحات في
الدوحه والكويت لابد ان نضعها في سياق اين
تصدر هذه التصريحات فهذه التصريحات تكون
مرتبطه بشكل كبير جدا بالموقف الذي تسمعه
هذه الدول خلال هذه الاجتماعات وباحترام
العلاقات مع المضيف ولكن ما هو واضح هو ان
النبره ضد الحصار هي في تعالن مستمر من
قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وما هو مهم حقيقه هو ان
نقرا البيان الذي صدر من دول الحصار
البيان الرباعي الذي جاء بعد قمه القاهره
وليس البيان المرتبط بقمه القاهره مهم ان
نقراه كرد على الضغوط الامريكيه
والاوروبيه على دول الحصار ان تبدا
بالتفاوض وان تنهي هذه الازمه سريعا
البيان يقول لي بشكل واضح واظن انه يقول
ذلك لاي مراقب ان الضغط يزداد بشكل كبير
جدا على دول الحصار لانهاء هذه الازمه
للتوقف عن اجراءات التصعيد وللتو قف عن
التعنت وبالتالي الدخول في تفاوض مباشر
وتقديم مطالبات واضحه ومطالبات واقعيه
ومنطقيه اتوقع خلال الايام القامه اننا
سنشهد ردا من دول الحصار على هذه الزيارات
وهذه المبادرات الان وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني يستمر في جولته وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي يصل يوم الاثنين الى الكويت هذه
الزيارات ستكون محوريه
جدا سيدس يعني يعني النبره ضد الحصار في
تعالن مستمر سيد يس ماذا عن النبره
الامريكيه الى اي مدى تعتقد ان الزياره
المرتقبه يوم الاثنين لتيلرسون قد تضع حدا
لهذا الغموض وربما التذبذب في الموقف
الامريكي باتجاه حسم هذه الازمه الان
سريعا في
المنطقه طريقه تطور الامور في واشنطن الان
اتوقع ان السيد تيلرسون سيقوم بامرين في
الكويت اولا سوف يقدم الدعم العلني الكامل
للوساطه الكويتيه بنها نهايه الامر نحن
بحاجه الى وساطه تاتي من الكويت لهذا
الدور والموقف الامريكي مازال نسبيا غير
متغير ولكن الان ربما اكثر قوه القضيه
المتعلقه بتمويل الارهاب هي ليست جزء من
المطالب ولكن التمويل المالي للارهاب يمكن
ان يتم العمل عليه من بين الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا والدول الاوروبيه الذين
لديهم السبل لمعرفه ما يجري وقد قمنا
بالعمل فيما بينه
ومع قطر
مباشره وعلى افتراض بانتباه
لقضيه وجود ربما تمويل مالي للارهاب من
الدول الاخرى الجزء الاخر من المطالب لا
علاقه له بالارهاب ولا علاقه له باي شيء
سوى قضيه السياده
والهيمنه اذا سنسمع من الولايات المتحده
بهدوء رسائله الى هذه الدول الاربعه لكي
تتخلى عن عن هذا السلوك ربما سيمر وقت لكي
لا يتخلوا عن الامر بحيث يبدو وكانه تم
هزيمتهم ا دكتور الانصاري يعني بكلمات
قليله اين باتت هذه الازمه برايك بعد هذا
التحرك
الدبلوماسي
الغربي هذه الازمه يبدو انها الان في في
عنقها الاخير اذا صح التعبير او في العنق
الذي ينقلنا الى زجاجه اخرى بمعنى اننا
الان نتكلم عن موقف واضح موقف يتبلور اكثر
في في واشنطن ضد الحصار موقف اوروبي واضح
ضد الحصار وضغط عالي جدا على هذه الدول
لتقوم بواجبها الحقيقي تجاه المجتمع
الدولي وتنهي هذه الازمه والكلام هنا طبعا
عن دول هل هو اقرب الى الحل ام اقرب الى
التصعيد الذي تحدث عنه البيان الثاني لدول
الحصار كما قال وزير الخارجيه القطري من
الصعب جدا التكهن بتصرفات دول الحصار ولكن
طبعا نتمنى الافضل دائما ونتمنى ان تكون
نهايه الازمه قريبه خاصه ان الان المساله
في سوريا والمساله في الملفات الاخرى باتت
معقده جدا والولايات المتحده والقوه
الدوليه بحاجه ان تركز في ملفات اخرى لابد
ان الضغط سيزيد الان على دول الحصار
ونترقب رده فعل دول الحصار على هذا الضغط
خلال الايام القادمه اشكرك من الكويت
اليوم الدكتور ماجد الانصاري استاذ علم
الاجتماع السياسي في جامعه قطر وكذلك كان
معنا من واشنطن الدبلوماسي الامريكي
السابق باتريك روس